sans le regard malade de Monsieur
Humbert il n'y a pas de nain fait
qu'elle l'imagination du Christ satire
qui fait une créature magique de cette
petite école hier américaine j'ai choisi
cet archive parce qu'elle commence
précisément par une question de Bernard
Pivot une très bonne question qui se
demande si l'avocate n'a pas assez
d'être pour toujours l'écrivain de
Lolita il faut rappeler qu'on est en
1975 et que Lolita a été publié 20 ans
auparavant en 1955 et la question de
Bernard Pivot se termine par une phrase
malheureuse ou plutôt par un mot
malheureux Nabokov c'est Lolita c'est
l'équation qu'on entend toujours
n'abocov c'est Lolita alors ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu agacé à la fin par le
succès de Lolita qui a été si
considérable que je sais pas que qu'on
risque de penser que vous êtes le père
d'une seule petite fille un peu perverse
là où l'archive est extraordinaire c'est
qu'on est dans un temps on a beau coq
qui est un écrivain d'origine russe qui
écrit en anglais surtout et qui parle un
français absolument magnifique va lui
proposer aucune réponse à la fois
brillante père-fille et absolument
profonde sur ce que c'est que la
littérature ce que c'est que d'être un
écrivain sur ce que c'est qu'un
narrateur Lolita n'est pas une jeune
fille perverse c'est un pauvre enfant
une pauvre enfant que l'on débauche et
dans les sens ne savaient jamais sous
les caresses de
de l'immonde monsieur et il explique
justement il voit très mal lu le livre
comme la plupart des gens ont mal lu le
livre puisqu'il n'a rien de perfide dans
le personnage de Lolita en dehors du
regard
de Monsieur Humbert il n'y a pas de
nymphette
Lolita Lana fait n’existe qu'à travers
la hantise qui détruit un beurre et ça
c'est une phrase très importante parce
qu'on se rend compte de ce que c'est
qu'un archétype littéraire en fait
aujourd'hui encore on appelle Lolita
toutes ces jeunes filles mais pas
seulement des jeunes filles des femmes
un petit peu plus âgées qu'on considère
être sexy sexuel sexualisé alors c'est
bien le sexualiser qu'il faut retenir
pour Vladimir un avocov puisque ce qu'il
raconte c'est en fait l'histoire d'un
sociopathe histoire même d'un criminel
le personnage de Imbert Humbert par son
esprit et par son regard malade par sa
langue malade
tient un discours sur ce c'est qu'une
jeune femme qui est profondément
problématique et qui a quelque chose à
voir avec la mort chez Nabokov en
réalité
je le répète et d'une fillette de 12 ans
tandis que Monsieur Humbert est un homme
mûr et c'est l'abîme entre son âge et
celui de la fillette qui produit le vide
entre ce vide ce vertige la séduction
d'un latrait d'un danger mortel la
société a pris ce texte dans ce sens la
plus littéral en épousant le regard du
psychopathe c'est-à-dire qu'on considère
aujourd'hui la petite lol ita comme une
nymphette à demi-mo pervers c'est le mot
emploi Bernard Pivot or ce n'est pas le
cas il est assez obéissant de se pencher
comme disent les journalistes
sur le problème de la dégradation
inepte que le personnage de la nymphette
que j'ai inventé en 55 a subi dans
l'esprit du grand public non seulement
la perversité de cette pauvre enfant a
été grattesquement exagéré mais son
aspect physique son âge tout a été
modifié par des illustrations dans des
publications étranges les étarchives
racontent aussi ce qu'on oublie toujours
et en particulier aujourd'hui que la
littérature c'est d'abord un regard et
une écriture c'est d'abord une voix
toujours se poser la question de qui
parle qui regarde alors là où l'archive
est profondément perfide pour moi c'est
pour ça que je l'adore c'est que
n'abocov regarde Bernard Pivot et finit
par répondre à sa question non son
succès ne m'agace pas je ne suis pas
content qui par snobisme ou simple
bêtise préférée être connu comme
l'auteur d'une Histoire d'Afrique qui
croyait bien supérieur à son chat ce que
j'aime dans la langue de Vladimir
d'avocov c'est sa précision c'est sa
profondeur c'est la beauté de ses
phrases en français ce que j'aime c'est
la longueur de ces phrases le tour de la
langue en fait qu'il joue ici à Bernard
Pivot et à tous les spectateurs
d'apostrophes et voici un aspect
essentiel d'un livre singulier qui a été
faussé savoir une popularité factice
[Musique]